well ladies you do get a little bit of
Matthew McConaughey shirtless in this
movie but you also have to deal with
some rather horrendous dentures you win
some you lose some
mud is written and directed by Jeff
Nichols it stars Matthew McConaughey ty
Sheridan Jacob Laughlin Sam Shepard
Reese Witherspoon Michael Shannon
amongst a lot of other people there's a
lot of people in this cast this movie is
about two teenage boys who find a man
who is stranded on the island you're not
exactly sure why he's stranded is he
stranded or is he there by choice I'm
not gonna tell you why he's there
because I want you to be able to
experience this film without knowing
that nevertheless these two boys one in
particular forged a really amazing
friendship with this guy and try to help
him find something that he is really
searching for this movie is one of the
best movies I have seen all year and I
am so glad that I went to see it this
weekend because it finally came to my
city it's been all over the place I've
been hearing things about it from
various festivals that have premiered at
this film is truly incredible this film
is written directed and acted with so
much passion this is one of those movies
where as you are watching it at least
with me anyway
I was so sucked into this world partway
through this movie I had that great
revelation that I've only had a couple
times during movies where you're sitting
there and you realize you remind
yourself wow I'm currently watching a
great movie I can't wait to see what
happens next I love when that happens
during a movie and mud is a film that is
so carefully crafted you can feel the
passion coming through every frame of
this movie not just from the director
and the writer who happens to be the
same person but from all of the actors
as they contribute to this film this is
such a dramatic movie it's also funny
and very light-hearted at times but it's
a film that had a surprising amount of
thrilling sequences that had me on the
edge of my seat and two performances in
particular that are two of the best I've
seen all year and one of them is just
from a boy ty Sheridan is so good in
this film as this young kid who really
starts to forge this bond with mud
played by Matthew McConaughey these two
characters in the way they interact in
this movie was so remarkable to me and
yet it was so simple because this movie
carefully crafts different characters
that you can see in real life I can see
that kid having that problem in real
life because I remember I had problems
like that when I was his age but there
are certain scenes in this
where I have seen these types of scenes
countless times in movies like for
instance a fight scene or an argument of
some kind or anything like that you've
seen these a thousand times in movies
but here these scenes that could be in
other films and just be so passable are
so riveting because you care about the
people the characters and that's because
they're so well-written and this film is
so carefully directed with pristine
cinematography that I was watching and
just drooling at how great this film
looked and that's something I keep
trying to emphasize in my reviews
Hollywood filmmakers out there guys you
gotta have good characters you gotta
have characters that we can care about
you gotta make us like them I mean I
just like them you gotta make us really
truly afraid about what could possibly
happen to these guys because you want
them to be okay despite the fact that
they're fictional and that's what mud
has it has real characters that just
seem so realistic and that's a credit to
these actors once again Matthew
McConaughey is on a terrific winning
streak of performances killer Joe was
incredible Magic Mike he was great and
here in mud he is just as good and it's
funny because I read an interview
recently with McConaughey where he
confirmed something that I've thought of
all along he said that he actually had
like his publicist and agents and
various people or whoever get him like
almost every negative review ever
written of something that he was a part
of and they read them all and he
apparently decided to change his career
and in doing so that confirmed to me
that what I do can actually help telling
you guys and other people what movies
are good and what movies aren't in my
opinion actually does help because this
guy is doing freakin incredible and now
he's an interstellar directed by
Christopher Nolan coming out soon and I
can't wait to see what else this guy
does because here he is oscar-worthy and
I gotta say the young kid ty Sheridan I
really do think he's Oscar worthy he was
so good in this film it's one of the
best young performances I've seen in a
long time Reese Witherspoon doesn't have
a lot to do in this movie staying with
Michael Shannon Sam Shepard is in the
film and he doesn't have that much to do
but the roles of these characters Phil
are extremely important and what they do
give to the film is very well done
everyone in this movie is on point the
film is crafted beautifully it's written
with such care and precision as
characters that are truly interesting
that you can really care about
Mudd is one of the best films I've seen
in a while it's definitely one of the
best films of the year my only issue
with the film is it might be a little
too long but I really think that
filmmakers used the length of this film
and the best way they possibly could to
expand upon the characters and make them
more fleshed out I'm gonna give mud an A
I strongly suggest seeing this movie it
is one of my favorite films so far this
year and I'm really glad to have seen
this movie because I was like man there
really hasn't been that many great
movies so far this year just really
placed beyond the pines
I like side effects and warm bodies
quite a bit but I want more I want more
films that are good like this that
surprised me
mud is one of them please check it out
so if you guys have seen the film let me
know what you thought below and until
next time guys thanks for watching and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]